las ruedas de un auto tienen un radio r
y se mueven con una velocidad lineal v
la v está en negritas para indicar que
es un vector de pronto el auto acelera a
velocidad 2 v cómo cambia la velocidad
angular de las ruedas pausa en el vídeo
y traten de calcular esto por su cuenta
resolvamos estos juntos para visualizar
lo que sucede vamos a dibujar la parte
frontal de un auto más o menos así
imaginemos que este auto se mueve hacia
adelante dibujamos su vector velocidad v
así como es difícil dibujar algo en
negritas le pongo una flecha arriba para
indicar que es un vector
este es el vector que está indicado en
el enunciado para denotar que es un
vector se puede escribir en negritas o
tener una flecha encima si queremos
indicar la magnitud de un vector la
magnitud de la velocidad es la rapidez
escribimos la variable sin ponerle la
flecha encima o la escribimos sin
resaltar la en negritas esto es igual a
la magnitud del vector velocidad que es
lo mismo que la rapidez veamos un punto
cualquiera en la parte exterior de esta
rueda
por ejemplo este de aquí acá está el
centro de la rueda y el auto se mueve
hacia la derecha con una velocidad v
cuál es la velocidad de este punto de
aquí la velocidad de este punto tendrá
la misma magnitud pero irá en la
dirección opuesta más o menos así esto
es uve negativo pero para el propósito
de esta pregunta vamos a pensar en la
rapidez la rapidez de este punto es v
que también es igual a la rapidez de
este punto de la rueda aunque la
dirección es diferente todos los puntos
en la parte exterior de la rueda van a
tener la misma rapidez v en vídeos
anteriores encontramos una relación
entre la rapidez y la velocidad angular
la rapidez que escribimos como v sin la
flecha arriba y 100 negritas es igual a
la magnitud de la velocidad angular
multiplicada por el radio otra forma de
expresar esto es decir que la rapidez v
es igual a omega sin la flecha de vector
ni los símbolos de valor absoluto que es
la magnitud del vector velocidad angular
multiplicada por el radio
y tenemos solamente cantidades escalares
la rapidez es igual a la magnitud de la
velocidad angular por el radio si
queremos la velocidad angular como
función de la rapidez dividimos a ambos
lados entre r por lo que la velocidad
angular es igual a la rapidez entre el
radio esta distancia de aquí es r al
igual que ésta si la velocidad pasa de v
a 2 v entonces esto pasa de v negativa a
2 v negativa y la rapidez pasa de ser v
hacer 2 v el doble de la rapidez y si
esto se duplica
entonces la velocidad angular se va a
duplicar también esto de aquí no se
eleva al cuadrado ni nada por el estilo
simplemente se divide entre r y r no
cambia lo único que cambia es la rapidez
y ya que omega es igual a v entre r si
duplicamos v
entonces omega también se va a duplicar
así pues como cambia la velocidad
angular de las ruedas se va a duplicar y
con esto terminamos